hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday my 30th 2020 what's going on
how ya how's it going how you doing how
you hanging in there I apologize that
the podcast is a little late no I don't
the [ __ ] are you going huh what do you
have to do you're gonna be one of these
stupid [ __ ] that's still going out and
about all the [ __ ] time with three
your goddamn friends going on a hike
with three your friends talking about
how Trump is miss handling this
situation listen I understand if you got
to run a couple of errands but these
[ __ ] people I write you know you know
I'm going for walks I walk around the
block I walked around the [ __ ] know I
was in the car right yeah I was in the
car right driving I'm safe safe to drive
but even then I barely do that I haven't
gotten gas and three [ __ ] ways right
I've been very I've you know I've been
very good about this right
so I'm [ __ ] serpentining let's a
little road and I come in there's four
people just hanging out working out
right next to each other outside cuz
they can't go to the gym and I just want
to be like please tell me you all live
together and you're all [ __ ] each
other I don't understand I just don't
understand why people are continuing
there's a park you know in my
neighborhood and you just I don't know
the few times I Drive down the street my
thing is I try to go out like once every
three days you know we just we go for a
little family Drive right we go on a
family drive zim zam zim come back like
a half hour later get a little fresh air
breathe a little different air is that
bad I don't know so anyway we killed by
these [ __ ] parks and you just see all
of these people out and their sword is
six feet apart but not really I'm
telling you man I'm telling you this is
like this is why you can't get mad at
Trump on this [ __ ] you can only get so
you can't just sit there and blame this
guy and now look at all these [ __ ]
mouth-breathing morons I don't know I
don't understand it I guess they wanted
to keep going maybe what they could do
is they could just start do you just the
government just shoots a pack of hikers
in each city
so these [ __ ] [ __ ] finally get
the message because the thing is is if
you don't if you don't have symptoms at
this point I think people think then I'm
good and then they go out and then they
expose themselves to somebody else
that's only 11 days in I don't know I
haven't been watching the news but I am
[ __ ] I I don't know his little faith
is I have a human 'ti I am still amazed
at people the level of selfishness of
people you know but I have noticed
behaviors have changed because I had to
go you know I got to get some food I got
to go out and get food so I went and
everybody had [ __ ] masks on and
gloves on in this place
last week nobody did so I think people
are basically getting it and we were all
standing six feet apart and they had a
little thing on the floor stand here and
we made sure we stayed away from each
other and you know and then even then
you know I took stuff out of the bag and
then you gotta wash you [ __ ] hit
throw the [ __ ] out wash your [ __ ]
hands doing everything I can't alright
but hey freckles old freckles here is
[ __ ] a freckles old freckles is
asymptomatic so far so far I am fine I
get a lot of emails from people that are
saying that they're losing their minds
which is so [ __ ] funny to me that's
just like as I understand it the boredom
or whatever you know what it is is you
got a lot of your freedom taken away you
know all your virtual reality [ __ ] you
[ __ ] selfies and all that type of
stuff and to like live you know the way
they did in the 1920s with not as much I
guess so you still have as much stimuli
at home but you can't go out just you
just need a little bit of perspective to
keep yourself saying cuz I've gone a
little stir-crazy
I go I go for my little hike I try to do
it at night you know cuz there's not a
lot of people around you know so I just
walked through my neighborhood I put on
the headphones I got
this [ __ ] ac/dc playlist that I've
been playing along to playing drums too
by the way
by the way the most underrated [ __ ]
ac/dc album I think is for those about
to rock came out a year after back in
black no way no matter what they did
people would have benched because back
in black was just such a huge [ __ ]
album and Phil Rudd kind of goes back to
a busier drum style that he said he had
on some of the earlier like if you
listen to the original recording of
problems problem child his bass drum is
way busier and then you listen to him on
if you want blood you got it playing
problem child live and he's doing the
meat potatoes bass drum on one and three
we're on the album he was playing it on
one and and I think the end of two and
then three
[Music]
tempos I'm like that I would I mean you
guys don't [ __ ] play drums you don't
give a [ __ ]
but anyway so here's my here's my my
playlist and playlist is called Bill
Rudd because I love a pun is that a pun
I don't know alright Co D now right one
of the great [ __ ] drum tracks he's
had and then off of that's all that's
awful for those about to rock then I
listened also often for those about to
rock
I put the finger on you that's another
great one then dirty deeds done dirt
cheap off of the dirty deeds album then
what's next to the moon of power rage
then get it hot off highway to hell
girls got rhythm off highway to hell and
if you want blood you got it highway to
hell so that's my like [ __ ] after I
do a little warm-up or whatever I do
that then I got my bass drum workout
songs cheap bill what are those mass
appeal
gangsta want to be starting something
Michael Jackson which has this killer
[ __ ] opening with the snare starts on
the end of three I believe this is how
much time I have and four and
then you hit one on the hi-hat and
you're playing sixteenth notes up to the
2:1 an-22 but the bass drum comes in on
e and of one it's so [ __ ] weird
trying to play that on time and that's
just a kill that's a killer bass drum
workout then I played a Michael Jackson
Jam which if you really listened there's
like two different bass drums going on
there there's the one that's way up
front in the mix and then the one that
that's kind of it's almost like ghost
note but on the bass drum the want and
song Led Zeppelin in my time of dying
Led Zeppelin and then my Holy Grail good
times bad times which I can still only
get two in a row but I've just really
been working on that song this entire
time I'm up to I played it at what 75 or
77 BPMS but I can kind of do that that
that sixteenth note triplet lick that he
does I can do it up to like 80 sometimes
85 PPM's but like I just don't have
control of it which and I what's [ __ ]
hilarious is I'm felt this drum track
doesn't bore all of you guys but what
I'm finding is just like and stand up or
in anything else trying to hit a
baseball and everything the more relaxed
you are the more power you have the
easier it is to play and the more
control you have which is crazy because
it's it's built up for 32 years
I just realized today I've been trying
this song with something I've been
chasing since I first started playing
drums 32 years ago
John Bonham only lived 32 years he got
his first real drum kit at 15 and then
was in the studio and recorded good
times bad times when he was 19 barely 19
so he got you know I read this doing his
son said this Jason was talking about
how he got that good in four years and
that was a whole new perspective that
just took my admiration for that guy to
a whole lot of level so anyway that's
what I'm really finding that if I tense
up like oh here it comes here it comes I
i crap out on the third one but if I
just chill and try to get that first one
I kind of
into the muscle memory of it and it's
been going really well so I'm gonna get
that man I think by the end of April or
whatever who gives a [ __ ]
it's taken me 32 years if I get it by 32
years plus May am I gonna give a [ __ ]
but I'm having a just a great great
[ __ ] time and anybody who wants to
just 100% improve on what it is they're
doing on a drum kit I can't recommend
Davey Lich's online lessons enough just
everything from so much [ __ ] sitting up
straight breathing not holding tension
in your face all of this [ __ ] that if
you're a self-taught person you know
when I was growing up there was all this
big [ __ ] about not taking lessons man
they're gonna kill your vibe man you're
gonna be in your head you're gonna play
like a scientist man and what I can tell
you is it really it's all how you apply
it all right and the way Dave teaches is
he's like hey just give me five minutes
a day with this thing five minutes a day
and then just go back to playing how you
always [ __ ] play you just do it five
minutes every day think about it a
little bit when you're playing and it'll
gradually work its way in naturally into
your playing and that's that's the way I
think that's like the best way to do it
so then you know you're hyper focus for
these five minutes but then when you go
to play you don't have to feel like oh
god I took 15 [ __ ] steps back you can
still sit down and wail and do all the
[ __ ] wrong at least if you're me but
yeah it was really an interesting thing
and it's kind of the same way what I
couldn't stand up that I found that the
more I gave a [ __ ] about a gig I mean
that's what really that's really all
pressure is is you all of a sudden
caring too much I think like this is it
okay I'm doing this let's you know blah
blah blah blah blah the thing is is you
have to trick yourself into not giving a
[ __ ] the more you care in a good way
it's a it's a very weird weird thing and
some people could do that naturally or
more naturally than others but it's
definitely a skill that can be learned
how to trick yourself into acting like
you're just [ __ ] doing a late-night
spot at a comedy club when you're
actually going on to do stand-up on
television or you're shooting a special
just things that you can do you know you
almost have to be like if you tape in a
special you got to be like you know [ __ ]
this special Oh [ __ ] stand-up space
it's special everybody has a special
it's not about who gives a [ __ ] [ __ ]
these cameras [ __ ] [ __ ] everything
I'm going out here I'm having a good
time and I'm [ __ ] around because I
kind of realized after a while of doing
this that I [ __ ] up jokes every night
but I don't really notice or give a [ __ ]
then sometimes my [ __ ] up turns into
like an appendix to the bed or something
extra I don't know what and the only
time I notice if I'm [ __ ] up bits
early on was if I was doing like a
special or I was I was taping a TV set
or something like that huh [ __ ] I missed
that tag in all of America [ __ ] they
don't they don't so I kind of learned
how to do that so I'm finally like
applying this to to playing drums and uh
my warmup song I'll give it who gives a
[ __ ] about what else might go there's
nothing going on in the [ __ ] news
other than people just staring watching
the news waiting for something good to
happen and God knows they're not gonna
[ __ ] tell you anything good so my
warm-up song after I do a little [ __ ]
around on the kit I plated that the
weekend star boy that's a fun one it's
also fun wonders to try different fills
and [ __ ] like that and makeup [ __ ] you
guys listen to his new album yet huh the
system misses my latest [ __ ] that I've
downloaded because of Andrew feminists I
downloaded night moves can you really
find me love in that album I was already
a fan of the weekend so I downloaded
after-hours love in that album Lamb of
God has a new one with the last one that
Chris Adler is gonna play on so I
downloaded that love
that spilt milk spilt milk milk Emmy LK
milk bill spilt milk by jellyfish
downloaded that cuz of Davey Lich and
then there's one I think I accidentally
I think I downloaded the wrong song I
downloaded an Eddie Money song called
there will never be another you and like
what the [ __ ] did I download that for I
was trying to think is there a drum fill
in here or something I don't know what
it is but I've been playing along to it
I like it
and then phil rutt had a solo album that
i didn't even know about called head job
and i [ __ ] love that album butthole
surfers independent worms saloon which
i've downloaded like 50 times every time
I phone shits the bed I always lose that
one for some reason I Drive I bought a
couple of songs by the drive-by truckers
courtesy of Steve Gorman used to be a
cop and never going to change and
goddamn lonely love
that's my dipping my toe into those guys
that's what I've been doing let me know
what you guys are listening to I got all
kinds of time I know Donald Glover's new
album came out today cuz my lovely wife
was playing it on the home speakers I
really liked what I heard on that
[ __ ] talented is that guy so that's
what the [ __ ] I'm listening to let me
know what you guys are listening to as
we sit here we try to make it through
the pandemic I mean honestly people uh
like there's always people that have it
worse than you it's a great mindset to
try and stay in like when I get you know
when I get like cabin fever I'll just
look up like worse ways to die and I saw
there was this one this Queen wanted
this guy executed and was gonna have him
literally sawed in half from the head
down and they started on his head and
then she goes wait a minute wait a
minute he's gonna die too quickly and
they turned him upside down and started
with his undercarriage okay
now you tell me how bad is how much
cabin fever do you have you want to go
outside and have that
happen to you anybody see that baboon
that ate that little [ __ ] deer alive
I couldn't watch it couldn't [ __ ]
watch it see so there's all of those
things all of those things you could
actually have the [ __ ] coronavirus
and be going to the hospital they don't
have a ventilator that could happen you
can have that excitement so you wouldn't
be going bored out of your mind as you
take a [ __ ] selfie of you of how
bored and crazy you're going you know I
mean all of these [ __ ] parents
talking about how they're going nuts at
home with their kids it's just like how
[ __ ] nuts do you think you they were
going in the 1800s you know when you get
legit diet some [ __ ] every [ __ ] ten
minutes and a grizzly bear could just
poke his head and be like oh there's
breakfast like he's at the [ __ ]
McDonald's drive-through take a couple
of your kids like a [ __ ] happy meal
let's get some perspective people come
on man you're better than this I'm
having a great time hanging with my my
daughter man dude she is crushing it
with the the what do you call tea the
tea ball she's been crushing the tea
ball she's a lefty I can't believe it
I'm so psyched she started to throw the
ball left hand and then she gradually
switched over to right and I'm trying so
hard not to kind of make her throw with
their left hand too you know I might I
want to just get you know she's a
left-handed hitter so I'm happy about
that I could deal with that [ __ ] but you
know I'm definitely who is that kid that
poor kid whose dad just from day one
decided he was gonna be a professional
quarterback he played for USC and he
played for the right Todd man - rich and
I remember reading out like when he was
in the crib his dad used to you know
when babies come out of the womb they're
like like beyond flexible you know what
I mean like they hammies are your
hamstrings are never more flexible than
when you're when you're first born his
base your whole body is like [ __ ]
rubber you know what I mean
and you know unless you're one of these
these [ __ ] yoga people like I don't
some of these people you know [ __ ]
crawl on the back around you know
coming back over the horizon with their
head looking looking looking over their
[ __ ] privates you know to me back at
their [ __ ] head that just disappeared
underneath them but some people can do
[ __ ] like that but basically regular
people so he would stretch his baby legs
every morning so he would he would still
have that flexibility the kid never had
McDonald's or anything like that I'll
tell you what's [ __ ] unbelievable is
he just decided he was gonna make it to
the NFL and the kid [ __ ] did it so I
mean that's one on the side of choosing
your kids dream yourself
as a parent so don't ever be afraid to
decide what your kid is going to be as
they have shown you know from Jim
Morrison the Todd man to rich and all
that type of stuff you [ __ ] do that
to a kid like when they get to college
or they get a little bit of freedom the
spigots gonna get turned on and they're
gonna go [ __ ] they're gonna make up
for lost time
as would have I so I never judged those
people although the press does pretty
harshly speaking of which did anybody
see that [ __ ] documentary I think was
on Amazon I watched it with my lovely
wife last night about those triplets
separated at Birth you gotta watch it
not [ __ ] how do I talk about this I
don't want to ruin it I'm not gonna ruin
it just watch it and I'll talk about it
in like a [ __ ] week or so I watched
that thing last night and I don't know
that's a tough one to watch as a parent
put it that way as a parent things
affect you differently I'm sorry
literally doing the thing that I [ __ ]
made fun of anyway
now having said all that I actually live
in a house okay
so I do have empathy for all you guys
living in apartments and studios and
that type of [ __ ] I just wish everybody
would you know I get that you have to go
I've gone out you know I got out [ __ ]
ran an errand here or two you know what
are you gonna do you got to do that but
I mean I stay away from [ __ ] people
so I just don't get still going to the
park where a park is just for people to
gather and even if they [ __ ] close
them down these [ __ ] people still go
it's unbelievable especially out here in
LA you know cuz everybody's got to
[ __ ] keep working out I mean I've
been I've been just doing like the
[ __ ] prison workout here at home with
like the stretches and Oh freckles all
freckles freckles is down six pounds I
mean I started working out before this
[ __ ] happen but I'm down six pounds
I'm playing some good drums I'm starting
you know go a little [ __ ] nuts here
but trying to do something positive
cleaned out my drum room I'm gonna clean
out the rest of the garage today I have
some gecko buddies of mine that live in
there I have one that has been there so
long that he's not even scared of me
anymore used to be so scared like I got
the I got like that gloss finish on the
garage floor
you know the garage is basically the
husband's house okay the house is the
woman's you know so I wanted it to be
nice so the fourth thing would try to
run away and he would be going like a
bastard but I mean he can [ __ ] he can
only go half a mile an hour because of
the finish I have on the floor so now he
doesn't even run away from me and
yesterday another one came and it was
even smaller and he was all aggressive
and running away and [ __ ] and I saw it
looked like he had a piece of plastic
stuck to his back so it's just like you
know I got I got hate you know I got to
get that off him so I got a stick and I
[ __ ] press down a little bit on his
back and he [ __ ] turned his lizard
face around with his little mouth open
which freaked me out and I dropped the
stick I'm no [ __ ] alligator man
whatever that guy's name was Crocodile
Hunter right so I [ __ ] then I was
like all right put you a little hard I
pushed a little harder then he couldn't
[ __ ] bite me and I reached down to
pull the plastic off of him and it
turned out it was just his reptile skin
shedding so I might have just started
the next virus
I went in and I washed my [ __ ] hands
immediately so now I got two little
geckos out there and I like that they're
there they're [ __ ] cool
it's a safe place you know the goddamn
snakes can't get them
I have names for them and [ __ ] and
that's it okay I'm [ __ ] going I'm
going out of my mind two people I'm
making friends with [ __ ] lizards I
don't know what to tell you I'm not a
reptile guy either I'm a [ __ ] dog guy
I like dogs I like horses I like goats
cows are cool
cows are actually beautiful you know
although I had one bad experience with
the [ __ ] cow as far as visually it
was [ __ ] sitting there looking at
this cow and it started you know they
got those giant nostrils and they got
the giant tongue it started [ __ ]
cleaning out its nose with its [ __ ]
tongue I mean it can't pick its nose so
it had to do it had to do but ever since
I saw that I was just like Jesus Jesus
[Music]
here's a question for you have I talked
about anything on this podcast yet how
far were into this am i I swear to god
I'm gonna have a point it's oh here's a
question I have what the [ __ ] is Oh No
I've been watching episode old episodes
of Adam 12 took me a second to get back
into the vibe but now I'm into it and I
got to tell you something that I noticed
when I was watching it yesterday or two
days ago the there's Martin Milner who
was the I guess he'd say he's the lead
and then Kent McCord Kent McCord if you
look at that you watch that an episode
of [ __ ] Adam 12 you tell me that Kent
McCord isn't Tom Brady's uncle or some
sort of distant relative it's [ __ ]
ridiculous he's like the [ __ ] he's
the goddamn Tom Brady of TV cops but you
know what's amazing how much how much
Los Angeles has changed like I I've
watched that show and every time they're
driving like one time I noticed that
they were definitely down Long Beach
another time I could tell they were in
Venice but so much of LA has just been
torn down and rebuilt and torn down
again and
built that I can't even [ __ ]
recognize anybody any of any part of the
city but the old cars a killer man saw
this one yesterday this [ __ ] woman
just she cuts this guy off and I'm not
even into this story I was just like ah
[ __ ] man look at that goddamn it was
like one of those 1970s Camaros but it
wasn't like the z28 who's sort of the
one that's had the the cool engine in it
but it wasn't all done up it was green
and had that [ __ ] shark nose front
gary Crosby's on it Bing Crosby's son
didn't he get all smacked around when he
was a kid one of those guys just abuse
the [ __ ] out of it right let me see let
me make sure before I put that out there
Bing Crosby child abuse was it him Oh
was it the other guy oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah was him I'm gonna beat you with the
bills whatever it is that's insult to
injury when your dad's beating you while
crooning well you know short [ __ ]
life he only lived to be 62 years old
what happened well that's what happens
that's what happens when you smack he
died of lung cancer poor bastard
anyway here's another positive way of
looking at the [ __ ] pandemic I
guarantee you three days into everybody
back to work I'm calling this right now
all the brilliant people on social media
are gonna be [ __ ] you know putting up
means going like being back at work has
me like where that next pandemic man you
know whatever the [ __ ] they're gonna say
for this stupid internet speak all right
it's definitely time for an ad read cuz
I've just plead on out of steam here
where the [ __ ] is he yeah that's goddamn
it what do I got here do I have no hands
I have one ad stamps.com anybody
everybody the way speaking of ads I
[ __ ] use that I might my hand was
starting to bug me it's an old injury I
have
from playing drums and it's in between
my thumb and my index finger you know
the meet day I write the little [ __ ]
web toe it was all getting sorna's
really bugging me and I had that CBD
[ __ ] roll-on and I put it on and it's
[ __ ] good as new
it's just like they say it doesn't just
numb it it actually takes the pain away
there's a free read alright because I
can't remember the name of the company
next time it comes up
alright stamps calm everybody you know
for all our sakes we need to avoid
crowds any way we can right now oh this
is great look at them [ __ ] rewriting
their [ __ ] ad copy perfectly but what
if you need to go to the post office
what if you need postage to send out
letters and packages we have the
solution stamps com anything you can do
with the post office you can do it
stamps calm print postage on demand and
skip those lines and crowds at the post
office plus you can actually save money
with discounts that can even you can't
even get at the post office plus stamps
calm is completely completely online
which saves you time stamps.com Brinks
all the services of the post office
right to your computer and the safety
and comfort of your own home office or
anywhere else you are hunkering down
right now whether you're you're a small
business sending invoices and online
seller shipping out products or you're
just working from home and need to mail
stuff stamps calm can handle it all with
ease simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail any way
you want to send once your mail is ready
just leave it for your mail carrier
schedule is free package pick up or drop
it in a mailbox no human contact
required it's that simple and like I
said with stamps calm you can get great
discounts to 5 cents off every
first-class stamp and up to 40% off usps
shipping rates the United States Post
Office Postal Service I think and now in
addition to offering discounted US
Postal Service rates stamps calm also
offers UPS services with discounts of up
to 62%
Jesus Christ that's almost free
stamps.com is a no-brainer especially
now save your time and money and keeping
you safe in these crazy times right now
my listeners get a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage in a digital scale without any
long-term commitment just go to stamps
com click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in Burpee URR
that stamps com enter / stay safe my
friends alright alright alright that's
good stuff that's all good stuff I'll
tell you right now if you got stamps
calm and then you get butcher box and
then you get whatever that CBD [ __ ]
company is that I read I do I think
you're doing pretty good you do a little
stretching you get some squats going
work the legs and the glutes so bill
what is your workout regimen they didn't
ask all right I'll tell you
so my stretching is I do the basic Bryan
Kest power yoga highly recommend his
stuff Bryan Kest power yoga workout
which is basically a forward bend then
you stand up you stretch go back a
little bit easy and then another forward
bend and then you go down into the Co up
into the Cobra or updog whatever they
call it and then the down dog I do that
I do the basic back stretches and then
what I've added to all of that is I do
the runner's stretch the hip thing you
know that one these are all yoga terms I
think and then I don't know how to
describe it it's basically alright you
know if you're sitting on your butt
right then you try to touch your toes I
do that one you know and then I do the
one same position except your legs are
out in like a V and you try to go down
I've been doing that one and then
another one you sit cross-legged
crisscross applesauce they used to say
Indian style you're not supposed to say
that anymore whatever that and then I
you try to go down in that position if
you're very tight like I was if you just
get like a little towel and you wrap it
around like you're at the bottom of your
bedpost it's a great way to kind of pull
yourself a little bit towards go slowly
go easily I am NOT taking responsibility
if you [ __ ] her knee
you goddamn disk all right listen to
your body all right and then I got a
couple of so ass stretches that I've
been doing it's almost like if you were
gonna do a a warrior one except the then
you just lift one hand straight up in
the air and then lean over to the side
the opposite side like whatever side
your leg is forward the one that's bent
the opposite side you lift your arm up I
don't know whatever I bet I just been
doing that [ __ ] getting a little more
flexibility and then as far as like my
leg workout I just do calves raises I
don't do it office stare I don't go
extra I just you know I just do three
sets of those whatever you want to do
then I do the ones where you're laying
on your back and you have your feet on
the ground knees are bent and then you
just basically doing pelvic thrusts to
count on the way up and then a four
count on the way down three sets of
those I do the donkey kicks and then I
do squats with one of those big exercise
balls up against the wall so I keep my
back straight three sets of 15 of those
that's the legs and then I just do curls
some tricep [ __ ] I do some back stuff
one of them that I like the best is the
one we act like you're picking up a
wheelbarrow that sort of motion so you
get between your shoulder blades which
is great for someone like me where my
shoulders kind of rounded in forward
from doing too much you know working out
on the front and I think that's it and
then I got some of those [ __ ] I can't
recommend these [ __ ] things enough
man everybody gets those foam rollers
which are kind of good but they just
sort of pushed down and they mush if you
get one of those they have like these
little I don't how to say this without
everybody laughing but these hard balls
okay and they come in different sizes
and different degrees of hardness all
right you have the smaller ones I use
that up against the wall you put it
between the wall and your shoulder roll
out your shoulder and then I use the
green ones for the front of my legs back
of my legs my calves and those ones are
[ __ ] incredible and rather than going
up and down the leg you go across it is
how I've been doing it just look watch
some videos alright that's what the [ __ ]
I've been doing and then I just been
doing this core workout which I just do
like crunches I do you know some oblique
things and then I do this one but you
just sort of you're just sitting up your
legs are rough you're in like a V only
your asses on the ground you know V for
victory doing that and what's funny is
when I do the crunches my daughter
thinks it's the funniest thing ever
whenever I'm doing them she comes in she
has a smile on her face and she leaps up
in the air like Hulk Hogan's finishing
move in wrestling in lands but first
right on my stomach and it's bad enough
when she just falls backwards but
sometimes she leaps up and literally
puts her hands above her head and comes
and really I should I sent the video of
it to Joe Bartnik and she see she's
really selling the move with their arms
yeah she's so damn funny so damn funny
but we've been having a great time
riding bikes in the driveway and playing
t-ball in the backyard
I say I'm gonna do t-ball like another
two weeks and then I'm gonna I'm gonna
try a couple underhanded see if she can
hit the ball oh my god she gets to that
level I'm gonna have a little bucket of
balls and just [ __ ] underhand in it
and then I'm gonna work to overhand yeah
then I'm gonna start stretching her and
a baby crib and then [ __ ] sorry
that's what happens that's what happens
you don't accomplish the things I
couldn't you got to watch out for that
all right here we go
he's nothing - I listen to a [ __ ]
song the other day this guy was singing
trash in LA and blah blah blah blah blah
which everybody does who lives out here
it took me a long time to realize that a
lot of people blame Los Angeles for what
sever whatever is wrong with them you
know I gotta get out of him and
everybody so huh it's like everybody's
like you we're all trying to find
happiness through
job success it's fleeting
it does it doesn't like it's not a
sustainable happiness you know where's
the other day like I got more
satisfaction I just came walking you
know around the corner I just saw my
daughter's shoes little sneakers sitting
on the floor and just that alone how
much that filled me up was better than
killing it on stage Oh bill you getting
into your fields man alright let's let's
read some of the [ __ ] questions here
for this week all right
helicopter why Akata hey Billy whirly
bird Billy were Liebherr yeah that's how
he wrote it I had mentioned on a podcast
recently that those those helicopters
that have the the wire cutters on the
front if you see these little things
sticking out there for is so god forbid
if you're flying in a helicopter and you
hit a a wire which kills more goddamn
pilots you know before it goes up into
your main rotor it hits one of these
things and it cuts it and I was like I
just don't know if that actually works
with those high tension wires
specifically because they're so [ __ ]
you know they made out of like steel
aren't they wrapped in steel or some
[ __ ] so anyways this guy writes and he
says on your mmm podcast from March 28th
March 28th what are you talking about
the March 28th this today oh god do I
have the virus
Oh today is March 30th oh so you must
listen to the third the Thursday what he
said you were wondering if those wire
cutters on helicopters actually work I
am a helicopter maintenance technician
dude that you are the [ __ ] you know how
to put together a [ __ ] a helicopter
that's amazing well you [ __ ] Jeff
Dunham I can say this I've seen a bell
412 cut the main power lines feeding the
city of Yellowknife everyone walked away
but the front was smashed in and the
frame was bent here is an article that
talks about it a bit oh yeah let's
[ __ ] see this I want a picture
all right well there's some wires
where's the [ __ ] helicopter Griff
Griffin chopper hit power lines during
military exercise in February
uh-oh it's military so they got the [ __ ]
out of there all right a worker from the
Power Corporation inspects the severed
power line Wow well that that looks like
that steel cable [ __ ] to me it has cost
2.4 million to repair powerlines near
Yellowknife after a military helicopter
accidentally chopped them in February a
Griff Griffin and Grif Fon they probably
is called Griffin Griffin helicopter hit
power lines near Yellowknife that's on
my bucket list to do stand-up up there
by the way knocking out power to the
entire city for hours the helicopter was
part of a military Arctic Ram training
course exercise sorry the Northwest
Territories power corporation had to run
on backup diesel fuel for ten days after
the incident the corporation trailed the
costs tallied the costs of the damage
and repairs including materials salaries
and hiring a contractor yeah I'm sure
that guy didn't overcharge [ __ ] [ __ ]
a manual DeRosa Joey Rosa's has an uncle
up there the company's president CEO
said the military has been very
cooperative they've been they've been in
contact where am i they've been in
contact with myself and asked us
basically to put the claim together they
provided us with all the information to
go through the process well that's cool
of them obviously they can't accept any
liability at this point but they've
certainly pointed I mean they can't
accept liability they [ __ ] did it but
they certainly pointed in the
appropriate direction to have our claim
process said DeRosa DeRosa said the
company DeRosa said the company will
build a military in the coming weeks
military officials have indicated they
are willing to pick up the cost if they
have found to be at fault in the
incident well yeah it was there and you
hit it
that the power the Department of
National Defense has been conducting its
own investigation
well I the only thing I can say is if
for some reason that was considered
military property and they accidentally
put these power lines on there in the
military didn't notice I think you're
paying for that one
they're Mounted Police yeah if you want
to see some creepy pictures helicopter
hits power line photos here we go yeah
that that uh these are not good oh Jesus
that things on fire two dead after
helicopter hits powerlines explodes all
four passengers in helicopter jumped to
the ground when it hit power lines in
Beakman tin New York and they still
dealt to died out of four two of them
had the [ __ ] cat gene and [ __ ]
landed on their feet man that's a real
thing understanding your body as you're
[ __ ] flying through the air some
people got that some people don't that's
good that half of them did I wish they
all did though Jesus Christ and I gotta
[ __ ] sit through this goddamn
commercial all right it's an old guy in
a laptop and there's an old person
looking around at them and back at a
house and now they're visiting their
grandkids and there's some happy kiddo
and they bought our little piece-of-shit
hatchback but you know what she can use
it principle comm ABC News all right
here's the chicken used to be on ESPN
it'll beat cancer oh my god then they
hit a [ __ ] house in an apartment
building geez Louise well there you go I
don't know how people hit those [ __ ]
things there's no reason to ever be
flying that goddamn low you're supposed
to listen what you do is you've know
where you're gonna fly in and during
your pre-flight they have on the map
they'll have a number
and it lets you know what the highest
obstacle is in each area and then you
fly 500 feet above it that's the way I
was taught the way I was taught you know
hands 10 and 2 that's how I still drive
you know the deal next thing you know
you [ __ ] driving with one thumb you
got your arm out the window you know
ladies you're putting your makeup on
guys you're fiddling with the [ __ ]
radio just in your ball bag it all goes
out the window all right that's what
happens you need to have that discipline
to understand that bad things can happen
to you all right all right
Obama droning bill you go off about
Obama droning people at picnics without
acknowledging the fact that Isis would
have been a major power in a third the
time if he hadn't no if he hadn't killed
innocent people okay I see how this
works
you know Isis wouldn't exist if we
didn't [ __ ] go over there and we
weren't [ __ ] sucking on their [ __ ]
oil nipple you know Jimmy Carter said he
called it 40 [ __ ] years ago this
country is addicted to oil he put solar
panels on the [ __ ] White House all
right
Reagan came in [ __ ] took him off and
said drill baby drill or whatever the
[ __ ] day that's what the [ __ ] they're
doing here's one for you have you seen
how beautiful the [ __ ] air looks
without all this this people driving
around on all of this [ __ ] I'm not
saying that that you know solar panels
when disposed of and all of that it's
probably people probably I'll make an
argument that it's even dirtier but we
shouldn't be [ __ ] over there it's an
outdated form of energy or at the very
least we could knock it down a
tremendous amount save a ton of [ __ ]
money my conspiracy theory is as far as
I've read the American dollar the only
reason why it has value is because
barrels of oil are measured in value by
US dollars per barrel right it wasn't
that what Saddam was trying to do with
Hugo Chavez they were going to start
talking about their oils in Euros per
dollar euro dollars per barrel and
then [ __ ] bankrupt our economy isn't
that what happened anyways he goes she
can't have it both way somebody has to
decide who lives and dies and I would
rather have a man of sound moral
character like Obama doing that than a
narcissist like Trump so when Trump
kills people it's bad but if Obama does
it then it's okay
Trump is a self-obsessed narcissists and
a pathological liar you choose you
bald-headed [ __ ] I've never said that I
like Trump you hear these [ __ ]
political I really hope the person that
read this is listening I've said you
people who choose by the color of ties
are [ __ ] ridiculous the same people
who give Clinton a pass and Obama clap a
pass are all over Bush and Trump and
vice versa and they're all doing the
same [ __ ] thing all right now if you
want to talk about being of sound mind
[Applause]
everybody then who's been president
before Donald Trump is is miles ahead of
this guy this [ __ ] pandemic hit and
he needed to be Roger Staubach he needed
to be Tom Brady he needed to be Joe
Montana and he became Ryan Leaf he
flipped out he started pointing fingers
he started blaming he [ __ ] himself he
[ __ ] himself all right I am I am highly
critical but I don't know 100 percent
blame the guy when we all know what the
[ __ ] information is and you still see
people walking down the street in groups
of threes and fours it's not all his
[ __ ] fault
all right so I'm just trying to what I'm
trying to do is level this off where
Obama's a saint and Trump is the worst
ever okay my buddy
Bartnik said it the best he goes Bush's
the worst ever he's the one that got us
into this [ __ ] never-ending mess over
there anyway none of this [ __ ] ever
would have [ __ ] happened if any of
these [ __ ] presidents since Jimmy
Carter has had the balls to say what
Jimmy said and we all would have been
living a better [ __ ] life and there
would have been you know that there
would have been none of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] would have been directed at us
we wouldn't have been over there okay
Isis happened after we got over there am
I crazy by the way they said we went
over there cuz they were part of 9/11
was never proved
they said they had weapons of mass
destruction we never [ __ ] found it and
now we're over there we can't [ __ ]
leave and just [ __ ] you know we have a
sense of responsibility over there
that's all I'm [ __ ] saying I'm not
saying the only reason why I pick on
Obama is because the media just treats
this guy like you know he's he never did
anything [ __ ] wrong and you know III
don't you know you're you're really
looking at him through rose-colored
glasses okay and there's a very simple
solution over there I think I actually
have the balls to say this as a stand-up
comedian
all right listen yeah it look I'm
getting I'm get a little passionate here
so I'm saying crazy things like I have a
simple solution to the Middle East
here's is the selfless decision all
right is that what we do over here is we
embrace new forms of energy and we wean
ourselves off of [ __ ] oil we take
advantage of oil that's over here for
whatever we need we become self [ __ ]
sustaining okay now the problem is the
only way to do this is that like you're
talking about you're talking the closest
thing to overthrowing the system that we
have here because all of these guys the
Trump guy that you hate the Obama guy
that you love Bush that you hate Clinton
that you love or the other way around
the Clintons that you hate the bushes
that you love the Obamas that you hate
the Trump that you love wherever you
stand on the other side of the fence
they all bow down to the same [ __ ]
corporations all right and when you look
at the oil companies and the Federal
Reserve and the banks and all that what
they have done
with this [ __ ] Ponzi scheme of
horseshit
[Music]
everybody is tied into the lie so if
they lose we all lose okay the only way
you don't lose is if you don't have any
[ __ ] money but even then you will
lose your Lucille you'll go through
whatever you know the tanking of the
economy but at some point we need so
what I am suggesting is we gradually you
know in a quicker pace look how clean
the [ __ ] air is two things if we just
embrace solar [ __ ] power electric
cars and video conferencing and all of
these [ __ ] jackasses that are flying
everyday who really don't need to okay
they're just used to face-to-face
meetings if you do enough video
conferencing what you guys like me I've
done a bunch of party I just did one
with Bill Bert that's gonna be coming
out we like this was kind of [ __ ]
great we had a great [ __ ] time
it was and I didn't really even notice
it so it's a great way to one of us got
in our cars you know gas powered cars
went out and just blew a bunch of
[ __ ] burnt
excu into the [ __ ] air and this
really like we can I think that we can
do a lot of positive things but I don't
think that we can do it until people
stop doing this red sox-yankees Bruins
Canadiens Celtics Lakers whatever the
[ __ ] you want whatever whatever your
rivalry is cowboys Packers right
San Francisco drives Los Angeles Dodgers
whatever if you keep [ __ ] doing this
and your team is never wrong and the
other team is always [ __ ] wrong that
that's exactly what's gonna prolong this
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right I want a
better life I don't give a [ __ ] if
you're a Republican or a Democrat if you
like Trump if you don't like Obama if
you don't okay I'm trying to bring
people together here all right we should
you know just make some positive [ __ ]
steps which also includes doing it
yourself like buying less [ __ ] and leave
in a nicer world for your kids hopefully
at some point we got to turn it around
because our parents didn't
what their parents didn't do it in
defense of them I don't think that they
really understood where they were
heading with the lifestyle [ __ ]
with what was being sold to them
although that [ __ ] book Silent Spring
did exist in 1962 Rachel Carson called
it so as you heard I had to type that in
to remember a [ __ ] name but soundless
spring hey I need to read that but I'm a
little afraid to [ __ ] read it but
instead I'm reading this amazing [ __ ]
book I'm still reading that Steelers
book you know I've been watching TV with
my wife at night because you know what
kind of dealing with the kid over here
all day long except when she takes the
nap and then I go out and practice drums
and I work out and then she's up and
then and then that's it that's our day
but I've been working my way through
this this book on the pittsburgh
steelers called
their life's work and it's come to their
first playoff game of their first Super
Bowl season and they're playing the
Oakland Raiders and the entire game is
up on YouTube and Curt Gowdy is the
announcer and dandy Don Meredith I
believe is the guy doing the color and I
have to tell you it is such a [ __ ]
man's game I am only three minutes into
this [ __ ] thing I'm only three
minutes into this thing and I just
cannot believe what has happened to
professional football and I'm not
talking about the hitting I'm just
talking about how much it was geared
towards a male an old-school smoked
marbles died in your late fifties early
sixties male crowd and it is [ __ ]
euphoric I almost went out and bought a
cigar in fact you know what the [ __ ] I'm
gonna do
when this shit's over I'm texting
bartnik right now I'm gonna have him
over to my house on a special occasion
right this thing they're saying now is
gonna go to April 30th so then I will
not have smokin one smoked one cigar
since January 13th so I got this [ __ ]
under control
I'm gonna have him over here and I'm
gonna [ __ ] watch the Steelers versus
the Oakland Raiders 1974 and we're gonna
smoke some [ __ ] stinks that's what
the [ __ ] I'm doing all right okay have I
lost my mind
I probably lost my mind a little bit
considering I said I can solve the
Middle East problem easily people I just
want what I what I would love is to just
get outside up watching CNN news Fox
News you know I'm a liberal I'm a
conservative there's nothing wrong with
doing that but just you know they really
[ __ ] they you know it's like the
owners of the Pittsburgh Pirates you
know they know they know that the people
know that they're [ __ ] him but they
know that they love the Pirates so much
the people are still gonna show up so
they can get away with being terrible
owners right now in that metaphor the
Pirates is your own country okay they
know in the end you love it so much
where you going you're still you're not
going anywhere
all right did [ __ ] Alec Baldwin leave
he didn't leave he stayed they all
[ __ ] stay all right so anyway yeah
buddy you're misinterpreting my
criticism of Obama as if I'm a trump
supporter I am not by any means and even
if he was the greatest president of all
time just his is open how openly [ __ ]
racist that guy is and and then the
depression that there's there's no
ramifications for it his open disdain
for people who aren't white I mean and
if you can't [ __ ] see that
agree to disagree all right that's it
okay
other than that saying that I'll tell
you you know I don't mind Mike Pence
I don't I know I'm sure he's [ __ ]
people think he's crazy with his [ __ ]
conservative [ __ ] but the way he carries
himself standing next to that [ __ ]
guy I'm like I like that's my
quarterback quarterback anyway or baby
it's better that he's away I have no
idea I don't know who knows I don't
[ __ ] know but he seems like like
that's the kind of guy I think he looks
like he's got a firm handshake
and you [ __ ] talk to him and he looks
you in the eye he seems like a [ __ ]
man to me all right he's not [ __ ]
himself all right
anyway coronavirus DNA testing hey Bill
I have I have good news the conspiracy
theorist that wrote in concerned about
people's DNA profiles being collected at
drive-through clinics
nobody is sequencing your genome from
those mouth swabs as a molecular
biologist I can tell you that it's an
incredibly expensive and difficult to do
so from such a sample and requires
instrumentation that would not be
available to these makeshift clinics not
to mention that it would be extremely
illegal well every every point you made
I was believe it gives a [ __ ] if it's
[ __ ] illegal you know this well we
don't even pay attention to the [ __ ]
rules of treaties that we've signed you
end treaties we I wouldn't stop them
believe it or not that that does still
make a difference to a corporation and
the government well that makes me feel
good I hope so I hope you're not one of
those people that works for this
corporation or the government and you
sent this feel-good email man anyway
they were definitely correct about the
government and corporations taking
advantage of hysteria but that is
usually done legally or through passing
of new legislation so so then you make
something illegal legal okay well we
went through the proper steps
have a look at the earn it bill if you
want to get freaked out love everything
you do stay safe and go [ __ ] yourself
yeah anyway you know I think the
solution to the
our consumption of oil in in the amount
of air travel is gonna have to be
regular people like us just I guess
buying electric cars in in you know if
you have like like I all things comedy
like I want to you know hopefully when
we come out of this to have pitch
meetings through video conferencing I
would like to do that and just hopefully
appeal to all of these studios would be
like the air was so clean and we would
like to be a forward-thinking company
not only with the projects that we
present to you but by the way that we
present them [ __ ] I should write that
down and then just video like pitches
[ __ ] instead of being another [ __ ]
[ __ ] on the forum okay that last part
that I just pitched might be eighty
percent about me and twenty percent
about the environment anyway my family
is totally freaking out about the virus
and we're having a falling out oh no man
you can't you can't do that you can't do
that alright I recently traveled back
home from the UK and I am legally
required to quarantine at home for 14
days
my family is urgently asking me to self
isolate in my own room for every minute
of the 14 days and to not step out of my
room at all I think this is ridiculous
and unnecessary so naturally I started
arguing with them as stupid stupid
[ __ ] move I've done everything that
the experts and doctors are telling us
to do and I'm a pretty responsible and
clean person even before all this
started however my family is
irrationally worried that if I step into
the kitchen to grab something to eat or
to hang out in the living room all alone
I would be spreading the virus and
affecting them well they're not wrong
dude you just flew back to the UK I
think you're being a little selfish but
god dammit if john coltrane could have
locked himself in the attic to write a
love supreme and his wife could have
brought some food out to him you could
do the same thing see it's all how you
look at it
all right if my family told me to stay
in a room for 14 [ __ ] days I would
get off on the challenge that they
wouldn't think that I could do it and I
would do I would stay in there 15 days
the extra day is a [ __ ] you you thought
I was sick you know be funny if you
actually started getting sick and then
had to be like that thing turning into a
werewolf you know right when you're
still you know mostly you and but
starting you're still 51% human and only
49% werewolf so you could just be like
come on man
suck it up stop arguing with them and
just stay in there and just stay in
there when you come out 14 days later if
you did in fact not have it don't rub it
in their faces this is an opportunity
for you to show them that you can love
them for two weeks straight okay don't
be a selfish [ __ ] anyways keep in mind
that I left the UK when it had only
about 2000 cases those were mainly in
London yet I still wore a mask and Santa
sighs throughout my journey well that's
good my country is partially locked down
and we've only got about 80 cases I
think about my family the only have 80
cases where I think my family is being
paranoid I keep telling them we've done
what we need to do and more but they
keep thinking about the zero-zero-zero
know about the point zero zero zero one
percent chance they will get sick and
die I keep telling him this way of
thinking is really unhealthy and I find
it difficult to stay in my room 24/7 and
no one in my family is at high risk
I have no symptoms and neither does my
sister who travelled with me please
weigh in on this I know they are overly
worried in paranoid due to the media
coverage what do you think I think
everybody is right in this situation
it's it's up to you if if it was me I
would just be like all right [ __ ] it
this is what I need in my room
and that's what I would do and I would
just stay in the [ __ ] room
and and I would just have them bring me
meals yeah I mean people there's people
in prison right now in solitary
confinement for like a [ __ ] month can
you stay in an apartment with a bathroom
with people bringing you [ __ ]
delicious food
well is England let's not get crazy
bringing you their attempt at Indian
food no the Indian food is good over
there anyway thanks it in case you're
wondering I'm from oh man yes you've got
fans everywhere nice until I pronounce
it incorrectly hi oh man from old man
how do you study pronounce that is it
Oman but that's how to say oh man oh for
God's sakes
when is Neil deGrasse Tyson gonna just
let us up we get it you're smart [ __ ]
how many [ __ ] times you gotta prove
it Oh Oman Oman say again woman oh man
oh man oh man this whole side of this
whole silence am I supposed to be saying
it this is my study time oh man oh man
oh man how many times I shall say oh man
oh man oh man oh right never forget how
to sail man you have fans from I'm from
oh man yes you've got fans everywhere
that's awesome
isn't there an f1 race in that part of
the world that won't be happening all
right last lastly but not leastly
all right advice on a sublease all right
hey Bill my twin brother and I live in
different states but we talk every day
your podcast is often a part of our
discussions because we're both salesmen
that spend a lot of time in the car and
thoroughly enjoy your show all right you
know what you need you need a good
[ __ ] stretching routine if you're in
the car specifically you're so as in
your lower body so you don't get sciatic
nerve issues in your [ __ ] your your
your vital organs still get all [ __ ]
bunched up speaking from experience here
bill can you stop preaching on this
podcast Jesus Christ sorry
look at you you're inside for a couple
days and all of a sudden you can [ __ ]
stall the middle-eastern prompt I can
solve the Middle Eastern problem easily
I said that and I was serious when I
said it until I heard it out loud Jesus
Christ bill anyways now to why I'm
writing you I recently bought a house in
doing so I broke my lease with an
apartment I thought I had read the
document thoroughly and I was in the
clear wrong according to their rental
agreement I am now subleasing the
apartment so I owe them rent until they
find a new tenant I gave them 45 days
notice paid $100 administration field to
sublease forfeited my security deposit
one month's rent
six hundred forty five dollars and paid
for a whole month that I did not live
there now with the mortgage and surprise
rent payment due in a week I am debating
on not paying the rent
I am debt free aside from my mortgage
and have perfect credit I know you're
not a lawyer but I would love your
feedback should I bail on the rent or
stick to the to the straight and narrow
thanks for the help
I would just call him up and say you
can't afford it and then see if they
blink and see if you can just come up
with a [ __ ] severance package you can
give them I'd start with that all right
you know I don't know what
and then you have to weigh if you want
to let the thing go to court because
then that's also gonna cost your money
but that seems like you go go on
people's court for that bum bum bum boat
oh babe booty buh buh buh buh or one
that you like oh my god y'all um yeah
that's what I would do I would come up
say listen I can't I got a kid I got a
kid on the way if you know the kid just
say you have a kid on the way and I just
I can't afford it okay is you know is
there a number we can come up with that
I can just give you some what's left of
my savings and we can just walk away
from this pitch um how about I can I
just give you two months rent all right
I'll give you two months rent and would
you and we just you know and but then
have some sort of legal document drawn
up that [ __ ] cancels that other one I
would try to negotiate with this person
first all right
because believe me there's been I bet
there's been plenty of people that just
[ __ ] blew it off and this person
probably doesn't want to have to go to
court again that's I would bet on that
try that first let me know how it goes
all right that is the podcast and I have
some apology to make number one I
apologize for saying that I could
[ __ ] solve the Middle Eastern problem
easily
number two I apologize if if anyway I
tried to make it seem like I was
supporting Trump and not Obama I'm just
trying to get people to think you know
not through the home team thing and what
else I was also wrong about this
pandemic I thought it was not going to
be a big deal and it was going to be
over in two weeks I did not bet on
people continuing to walk in groups
groups of threes and fours by the way
how [ __ ] bad are you as a parent that
your kid still goes to spring break and
also goes on TV and he's not worried
about you kicking his [ __ ] ass I mean
that is just complete [ __ ] failure as
a parent I know everybody gets mad at
those kids but you know you can't get
mad at kids who has shitty [ __ ]
parents that you know there's obviously
no [ __ ] ramifications for what
they're doing unbelievable alright I'm
going to can
10 you to do exactly what the [ __ ]
they're telling me I'm gonna continue to
stay inside every couple two or three
days we go for a drive and that's it
it's just me my wife and my lovely
daughter
my soon-to-be prospect first woman to
make it into MLB daughter crushing it
that's it all right that's the podcast
hope I brought you some laps whatever
people don't take what I'm saying during
this time to [ __ ] seriously there's
not a lot to talk about this not a lot
going on in the news I'm not watching
the news and I'm not really living a
life beyond my [ __ ] house and walking
around the block so other than that I
mean I don't know the other than
occasionally running a [ __ ] errand so
I'm gonna go a little [ __ ] nuts too
but I think it's big to stay positive
here don't complain and just think about
you know you know there's people in
[ __ ] prison right now you know you
know newly gone to prison don't know how
to fight and someone wants to [ __ ] them
in the ass and they know it's coming
alright just always remember that story
ok you're doing they would [ __ ] take
that dick in the ass a hundred times
over - then get out of prison and just
live you a [ __ ] pandemic life trust
me will mate I mean they wouldn't take a
hundred dicks in the ass I got to work
on the math on that but somewhere in
there is a life lesson
all right go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check
in on you on Thursday